all right a lot of people have asked for
my opinion on this Lauren Daigle
situation Lauren Daigle just for some
background is a Christian singer she's
exploded in popularity over the last
year or so she found a lot of success in
the mainstream as well and this has not
sat well with some maybe many of her of
her Christian fans and then Daigle went
on Ellen a couple of weeks ago and the
criticisms from many fans were ramped up
even more because she appeared on on
Ellen and the woman was she's she's
basically been ripped to shreds for how
she dresses for the shows that she
appears on for the way she speaks and so
on and so some people have even
apparently watched her on on TV giving
interviews and and they've counted a
kept track like I guess they have a
notepad they're keeping track of the
number of times that she says the word
Jesus and she doesn't say it enough
they've decided so that she's been
criticized for that that was all leading
up to leading up to this week and I've
been on the record saying and I'm not
you know i lauren Degel is it's not my
kind of music so I'm not really a fact I
can't call myself a fan of hers I think
she's a she's a good singer but just not
my type of music but I have kind of
noticed some of these criticisms
especially around when she appeared on
Ellen and and I've been on the record
saying that I think a lot of that is
just petty and and it's kind of
embarrassing for Christians it makes us
look it just makes us look petty and
ridiculous um but then this week she was
she was interviewed on a radio show and
and she was asked straight up whether
she thinks homosexuality is a sin and
this was the answer she gave she said I
can't honestly answer on that in a sense
I have too many people that I love and
they are homosexual I don't know I
actually had a conversation with someone
last night about it I can't say one way
or another I'm not God so when people
ask questions like that that's my go to
like I just say read the Bible and find
out
for yourself and then when you find out
let me know because I'm learning too now
this answer is obviously absurd the
Bible is clear on the subject there's no
ambiguity there are there are there are
issues that are more theologically
complex and less obvious when you look
at the text but this is not one of those
issues the Old and New Testaments are
clear about the sinfulness of the
homosexual act romans 1 26 through 28 is
just one example there are many there
are many others and in I I agree with
Loren Daigle in the sense that yeah go
read the Bible and see it for yourself
now Daigle though says that she doesn't
know what the Bible says and that's kind
of hard to believe if it's true though
if it's true that she doesn't know the
Bible says then her knowledge of the
Bible is very sorely lacking and if
she's going to make music and make lots
of money making music that's supposed to
worship a glorified God then you would
think she'd want to know who God is and
in order to do that she needs to go read
the Bible but if it isn't true okay if
if she knows what the Bible says but she
said she doesn't know then she's not
being honest and either way it's just
not good now like I said she said in
there read the Bible and find out for
yourself
that part is good and that was a good
part now if she had just said that and
left it there and said hey listen you
can read the Bible yourself and find out
about that that would have been kind of
a dodge but I think it would have been
an acceptable Dodge because at the end
of the day she's encouraging you to go
read the Bible and so I would say fine
or you know I think even better and
maybe this is just a tip for anyone else
out there who is uncomfortable with this
question but maybe asked it you know if
you're a person of some prominence then
what you you you could just be honest
you know I think honesty is a good
policy and you could say listen the
Bible says that it's a sin I personally
struggle with that I struggle to balance
that with the love that I have for my
gay friends and my gay family members
and so on
so it's just that something that I
struggle with and it's a balance that
I'm trying to strike and you know to be
honest there are times when I don't
really understand why it's a sin but I
accept the truth of God's Word and I and
I pray that he'll help me to better
understand it and I and I hope that you
will pray for me also you know I think
an answer like that because I think
that's basically what Laura and Daigle
was getting at and if she had just said
that it would have been honest and how
could you criticize her she's being
honest in that case and she's saying
look I there are there are things in the
Bible that we all struggle with so you
can be honest and just say as long as at
the end of the day you're still
affirming the Bible as the authority and
and you're not lying and saying you
don't know what's in the Bible when of
course you darn well do no so that would
have been fine but that's not the answer
that she gave she gave an answer that
was quite different than that and and
the the whole thing of I'm not God you
know that just makes no sense that is
the the silliest way of deflecting
because of course you aren't God but if
you're Christian then you believe that
God's view on the subject has been
revealed in Scripture and if you're
Christian then you believe that our view
your view should conform to God's view
and if it doesn't conform then that's a
struggle that's something you need to
pray about if you don't believe if if
you don't believe either of those two
things that I just said that God's Word
is it revealed in Scripture or that our
review should conform with God's view if
you don't believe either of those two
things then in what sense are you
Christian and you see that that's that's
the thing here
about people say well it's not black and
white it is black and white when it
comes to something like this because the
Bible does clearly say repeatedly that
homosexuality is a sin so as a Christian
there's really you either accept that or
you don't you either accept it humbly or
you don't and if you don't accept it
then what you're saying is the parts of
the Bible that articulate this this view
if I'm a
sexuality those parts are wrong and if
you're saying those parts are wrong then
either you're saying that God is wrong
which would be which is another way of
saying that he's not God or you're
saying that the Bible does not actually
fully and truly reflect the true God's
truth and if you're saying that then
where else in the Bible is it not
reflected you're saying that that part
of the Bible is fallible you've just
kind of decreed that well then what else
what other parts of the Bible is
fallible and if any part of the Bible is
fallible in that sense and in a sense
that it that it communicates something
that is simply a it communicates a it is
wrong on a moral truth if that's what
you're saying then you have just made
the Bible itself fallible and you just
can't do that
so when a Christian calls something a
sin they're not claiming any kind of
special divine authority they're simply
recognizing God's divine authority so it
would be like if you ask me is tax
evasion illegal it wouldn't make any
sense for me to answer hey man I'm not a
lawmaker okay I it that's not up to me
to decide I don't decide what's illegal
or legal yeah well I don't have the
power to make something legal or illegal
but I don't need to have that power I
don't need to be a lawmaker to simply
identify the things that the real
lawmakers have made legal or illegal and
the same is true of the divine lawmaker
so yes it's true that Laura and Daigle
isn't God but that doesn't mean that
Lauren Daigle needs to be God in order
to identify a sin she can still identify
it according to what God has said and if
she chooses not to then there must be
some other reason it's not it's not that
she's not God there's another reason why
she's not identifying now with that said
I must also
mention that in my opinion the manner
and the tone and the tenor and the
volume of the criticism that Daigle has
faced from Christians has been a bit
over the top and even before this
unfortunate interview answer she was as
I said constantly harangue and scolded
for every little petty thing and then
once she gave this answer
III I could detect from some Christians
not all but some almost something like
Glee like they were happy they seemed
happy that she that she said this
because it vindicated their own
criticisms of her so they said see I
told you so she's a heretic yes she's a
heretic yes now they obviously didn't
say that explicitly but that was kind of
the tone and I'm you know I'm
uncomfortable with that here's the thing
until you have actually faced backlash
from the Christian community deserved or
undeserved backlash but until you've
faced it on a on a on a larger scale
then you really don't understand how
vile and petty and venomous it can be
okay I have faced it I'm not gonna
rehash it all now but when I took my
stance on how to interpret the book of
Genesis in particular the creation story
and a lot of Christians decided that my
view was unbiblical the the response
from a lot of Christians was just
absolutely disgusting to be honest not
across the board not across the board
but across much of the board there
of people that it didn't seem like they
were looking to defend God's Word it's
more of these were prideful resentful
people who seemed to take a certain Glee
in tearing me apart and not just me but
just tearing somebody apart because they
they think they've detected that someone
is wrong about something theologically
and so they can come up and prove how
well they know their Bibles and they can
tear someone apart and in that sense
prove how holy they are there was a lot
of that I experienced a lot of that not
just not a little bit that a little bit
but but quite a lot now I don't think
that my view on that topic is at all
comparable to what Daigle said so I'm
not looking to draw any comparisons
there I happen to think I was right
biblically it's clear that Daigle is
wrong but I only bring this up because
through that experience I got a look at
Christians from another angle and it was
enlightening you know it really was it
kind of it was it was it was it was an
eye-opening experience for me so when
people say that Daigle gave that answer
in order to avoid being attacked by the
world that's true I'm sure that probably
is why she gave that answer but have you
ever been attacked by Christians because
that's no picnic either I assure you it
is just as vicious just as intense just
as often slanderous and dishonest and as
I keep saying the word petty but petty
as well to the exact same degree you
know I and I can I can compare it
because I've I've been attacked plenty
from that it from from the world from
people who hate Christians and so on
I've experienced those attacks plenty
and I've also got not as often but a few
times I've got it from the other side
and it's really indistinguishable it's
it's the same so
how should we approach Lauren Daigle as
Christians I think we need to correct
her I think we need to be we need to
affirm what the Bible says but we should
do it with some grace and patience and
forgiveness and we should realize that
her response in that interview does not
vindicate the petty resentful attacks
prior to this and we shouldn't be so
incredibly eager to tear someone apart
for stepping outside of whatever box
we've set up and I'm not referring to
her answer on homosexuality when I say
that okay because that's not a box that
we've set up that's if you if you want
to put it that way that's the box that
the Bible sets up but I'm referring more
to all the other criticisms before that
I don't like how she dresses I don't
like the answer she gave there I don't
think she should go on that show no she
shouldn't have gone on that award show I
don't like know you know her music has
changed she sounds too much like Adele
now I don't like that I don't like it's
all that stuff as I said it's it's it's
embarrassing for us as Christians it
just makes us look horrible and not not
in a good way either because I know you
say that whoa whoa who cares what the
world thinks of us yeah but it's not
good if we look horrible because we're
actually being horrible that's not good
because in that case we do we should
care what the world thinks of us in that
situation because if we're being hot if
we actually are being horrible and the
world looks at it at that and sees it
we're giving them reasons to ignore to
ignore us and to ignore the faith and to
ignore the Bible and so and so it does
matter actually I think there's another
thing we need to consider here as well I
think we need to reevaluate Christianity
as its own genre of entertainment you
know there are there are
singers and Christian shows and
Christian movies Christianity is its own
its own thing its own its own genre and
the problem first of all is that anyone
can become a successful Christian artist
in any of these mediums just by talking
about Jesus in a song or in a movie and
so it's like that that South Park
episode from years ago where it's it's
very easy to exploit the Christian genre
and make lots of money because the
theological and artistic standards are
very low a relatively mediocre musical
artist no matter their actual religious
views can find enormous success in the
Christian music world if they just
tailor their songs to be a little bit
more jesusí and so in that South Park
episode Cartman takes normal pop songs
and just puts in the word Jesus here and
there and then he becomes this this you
know platinum-selling Christian artist
and that that's that's kind of how it
goes because the standards are so low
now I think that Daigle is talented i
she's not mediocre
as I said I don't listen to her music
it's not my kind of thing but she does
have real talent still the point stands
generally speaking so if if we view
Lauryn Daigle not as a Christian artist
of the Christian genre but just as a pop
artist who happens to sing about God's
sometimes then her answer on
homosexuality is a non-issue it doesn't
matter because she'd still be a person
who makes relatively wholesome
family-friendly music and her
theological views would be of no
consequence in that case we only see it
as consequential
because we see the Christian
entertainment world as a ministry and
then when someone in that ministry has
heretical views on something we react as
though our pastor or our priest had
those views but these are not pastors or
priests and this really is not a
ministry
the Christian the Christian
entertainment world that's a business
first and foremost way before it's a
ministry it seeks to make money okay
which again is fine but it should do
that without the pretension of being a
ministry because that's what I think
gets people hung up and that's where the
confusion comes from you know I think
ideally there wouldn't be this
delineation between Christian
entertainment and regular entertainment
that that's that's the problem that
shouldn't exist really there there was
no such delineation for the first say I
don't know 1980 years of Christianity
for all that time up until very recent
times you had artists and sculptors and
playwrights and authors and poets and
even filmmakers for a period of time who
happened to be Christian and who would
sometimes produce great and beautiful
works of art that would glorify God they
would produce religious art sometimes
but they would also produce art that was
less explicitly religious because they
were just artists that's all they spoke
what was ever whatever was in their
hearts at the moment that's what they
that's what they painted or sculpted or
wrote about or whatever and and that's
it they were they were artists so it
didn't so back then it didn't really
matter as much if da Vinci or
Shakespeare or Dostoevsky or Dante or
whoever happened to Harbor personal
views on some theological topics that
were unorthodox or heretical you know it
didn't really matter because nobody
looks at the personal life and the
personal views of Dostoevsky and
declares that okay well I guess crime
and punishment is worthless because of
that nobody does that that's only the
dynamic now because Christianity has
become its own business it's become its
own genre and I think I think ultimately
we need to get away from that so to
review
Lauren Daigle's answer on homosexuality
was absurd
Lauren Daigle is not a theological
Authority she should not be looked at
that way nobody ever should have
expected that from her and nobody should
expect that from pop artists of any kind
I think Lauren Daigle should be looked
at as a pop artist not a Christian
artist and if we look at her that way
then who cares really but at the same
time I think we as Christians also need
to re-evaluate the way that we respond
in these situations and the the image
that we project to the world when we
attack like hyenas
anytime someone offends us or crosses us
even if we have legitimate reasons to
criticize and with Lauren Daigle I think
there have been really illegitimate
reasons to criticize and now she's given
us legitimate reasons but in both cases
I think we need to just look at how we
respond and you know try to have a
little bit of grace and I know and I say
all that I know that certainly I speak
first and foremost to myself because I
know I need to work on that but we all
do we all do as well all right thanks
for watching thanks for listening
everybody Godspeed